the Joe Rogan experience that's that
that's kind of like the mission of my
show is to remind people how we got
Trump people want to pretend that
corruption in lying started in January
2017 the Afghanistan paper just came out
Joe that revealed that three
administration's in a row lied
completely 100% about Afghanistan from
the day they took over to the daylight
left stuff like Donald Rumsfeld saying
we don't even know who the bad guys are
we have no idea who they are well why
are we there well it may because of the
couple trillion dollars in rare earth
minerals I don't know how they really
think that maybe it's we would go to war
from minerals come on he was crazy would
try to steal somebody's natural
resources do we use upset at what a
small story it was I'm upset what those
papers came out and then no one really
even talked about and barely got it
nothing so ain't nothing it justifies
everything Tulsi Gabbard has been saying
these Wars I rely and [ __ ] and we
got to get out of them and that that
that that she's not the one lying about
him the one that's been lying about him
has been our government including Barack
Obama that's what the Afghanistan Papers
proved that they've been lot we've been
lied to her with the paper side some
people so what happened was they did a
study just like the Pentagon Papers
right they do their own study that
reveals that they're lying
so they interviewed four hundred people
that were like in the militant rolls
into the military and contractors and
all the kind of people to find out so
they can know what will happen in
Afghanistan so they revealed all this
the people who they were interviewing
revealed all this that at the beginning
of the board they didn't know who that
they still don't know who's the bad guys
who were killing they were lying about
they would lie that it's going well and
then their personal writings would be
revealing that they didn't know what the
hell they were doing and so it was it's
worse than you think but we can still
just keep sending four billion dollars a
month they're just keep sending it just
keep sending it for what no one knows
we're not leaving trumps didn't take us
out here it's gonna it's he's up for
reelection a couple more months we're
still in Afghanistan he didn't do what
he said he was gonna do nobody does
that's the problem and that's why we got
Trump in the first place because Brock
Obama comes in as an anti-war guy
immediately gets rolled by the
military-industrial complex just like
Trump did I believe that
believe that Trump his druthers would
get the hell out of the Middle East
right but he doesn't really have any
druthers he's like okay I'm done doing
that because they rolled me hard enough
three years of Russia gate I'm gonna do
what they want well you saw the
conversation that he had with one
reporter we talked about the
military-industrial complex and about
how they want to go to war yes I mean
Trump looked actively while in office
this is like an Eisenhower thing like as
he's leaving while in office it's
talking about the military barely got
mentioned I know and so I so I think
that's why the establishment wants to
get rid of Trump even though he does
their bidding gives them their trillion
dollar tax cuts nobody asks how we're
gonna pay for it he gives him he tries
to go into Venezuela he tried he tried
to do it you know he's doing Iran he
didn't come out we didn't get out of
Syria we're not out of Afghanistan he's
sending more people back to Iraq it's
amazing what what's happened the exact
opposite of what he ran on is happening
so why do i why do I think this happens
it's because just what Eisenhower said
is he left he says did we the undue
influence of the military-industrial
complex and Joe mentioned they just
invented 131 billion dollars more worth
of work for Raytheon and Boeing and
Albertan how much money that's the
recording music business make a year
I'm a t-bill I mean how much does it
we've just invented a whole nother
economy just since Trump got an elected
one hundred and thirty one extra billion
let me just think what you could do with
that you could build 131 Yankee
stadium's do you think every year
non-sena Klee do you think that a lot of
this impeachment stuff and a lot of the
scandal stuff is really a distraction
for a lot of these things they're
pushing through yes it's a hundred
percent distraction and just like I told
you because if they really believed that
he was doing all these things and he
wasn't why would they keep giving him
extra money to go bomb people that his
own because they they they don't try to
put handcuffs on him so that's how you
know they're full of [ __ ] and the reason
why they're coming at Trump in the wait
there's there's ways to so now they're
starting to oppose him because of this
Iran thing so now you turn on CNN and
Chris Cuomo goes hey why doesn't
Congress do its job and take back the
War Powers that they gave it to the
president under this a um so now which
is what I predicted what happened with
Trump the silver lining of a trump
residency was all the [ __ ] that the
Democrats Republicans have been agreeing
on which is war frakking open the Arctic
to drilling now all that stuff gassing
immigrants at the book now we're all
going to become aware of it well the
Democrats spent three years doing
freaking Russia gate so they didn't ever
oppose him on that stuff and they let
him keep doing it and so now people are
starting to become aware of what's
happening and so now Chris Cuomo is
going hey why don't why don't we why
does it in Congress do their job why are
you letting crazy President Trump well
they just gave him 131 but they they
gave him his spying powers again through
the Patriot Act they this guy who's
working for food and you're gonna give
him spying powers you [ __ ]
bullshitter they're all [ __ ] [ __ ]
errs it's a weird scam yeah Joe if you
thought a guy was working for Putin
would you give him an extra 131 billion
dollars to go bomb anybody at his own
pay by the way that's also intelligence
is that a rhetorical question
yes so so that's why and you know people
people give me a hard time about
supporting Tulsi right it's like why use
but I think it's really important to
have an anti-war voice that has you know
speaks from experience she's actually in
the military right now
she actually volunteered to go serve in
their illegal wars and then they smear
for it it's kind of amazing
[Applause]